the owner of a restaurant wants to find
out more about where his patrons are
coming from one day he decided to gather
data about the distance in miles that
people commuted to get to his restaurant
people reported the following distances
traveled so this is our data right over
here he wants to create a graph that
helps him understand the spread of the
distances and the median distance that
people traveled what kind of a graph
should he create and you can plot this
data in many different types of graphs
but they tend to depict things in
different ways for example a line graph
shows a trend over time he's not
interested in a trend over time so a
line graph doesn't make sense or line
graph could be one very a trend of one
variable with respect to another
variable it doesn't just have to be time
but he doesn't want to see a trend here
a bar graph is good when you're trying
to Bucket things put things into buckets
and see how those buckets are performed
performing once again that's not exactly
what he wants to see pie graph if you
want to see kind of how things make up a
whole that's not what he wants to see
right over here a stem-and-leaf plot
does help with distributions a little
bit but it really doesn't tackle the
median distance and the spread really
really well so the one that does and
especially when people talk about
medians and spread is a box and whiskers
plot and I'll show you how to do it
right now box and whiskers and what a
box and whisker plot literally does is
it shows the spread of the data it
splits it into quartiles and I'll talk
about that in a second and it also tells
you where the median of the data
actually is and that's one of the things
that the owner of the restaurant cares
about so whenever you're dealing with
medians and box and whisker plots deal
with medians the first thing you want to
do is order all the numbers because the
median is really the middle number when
you order them all up so let's order
this so let's write it in order so first
we have one so get rid of that one then
we have one two right over here and then
we have another two right over there
that's all of our twos then we have this
three that three and then we have that
three so those are two people who have
to travel three miles to the restaurant
then let's see do we have any fours we
have one four right over there and then
and we have another four right over
there then let's see do we have any
fives actually I just realized that I
lied it I skipped one of the one so we
have another one right over there so
let's write that one right over there we
actually had two ones and then let's see
do we have any fives we do not have any
fives over here do we have any sixes we
have one six right over here and then we
have no more sixes do we have any 7s we
have one seven right over there
eight we have an eight right over there
and that's the only one let's see do we
have any nines no nines any tens yes we
have a ten
do we have an eleven yep eleven do we
have any twelves no twelves no 13 14 14
and we have a 15 these people like most
like this restaurant they're traveling a
good bit then we have a 20 and then we
have a 22 so I've ordered all the
numbers let me just make sure I haven't
skipped or gotten some duplicates so 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
people were surveyed 17 patrons of the
restaurant we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 all right it seems
like I got all of them and I've ordered
them now now the median is the middle
number we just said that we had 17 of
these numbers so we want the number and
so it's an odd number of numbers the
meet the median actually will be one of
these numbers it's actually the middle
number it'll be the number that where 8
or larger and 8 are smaller so 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 so it looks like this is our
median it will be the 9th number then
you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 that are larger
so 8 are larger are smaller than 6 8 are
larger than 6 so 6 is the middle number
if we had an even number of numbers here
we had two middle numbers then we would
take the average of them when you have
an odd number of data points then you
can just take the middle one so this
right over here is our
median and then when you do a boxplot
what you want to do is you want to find
the median of the set of numbers that
are smaller than median than the median
and you also want to find the median of
the set of numbers that are larger than
media than the median and these are
called the first quartile and the second
quartile because when you do that you
split your data into four sections or
quartiles core you'd only associate with
four so let's look at this somewhat list
the set that's smaller than 6 so we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 numbers so it's an 8 if
you have eight data point you're going
to have to actually have two middle
numbers so for example you have these
two right over here are the two middle
numbers three less three more you can't
just pick the two because if you just
pick the two you would have three less
and four more and you can't just pick
the three because then you would have
three more and four or less so these are
our middle two numbers so the median of
this group right over here is 2.5 I
averaged these middle two numbers and
then let's do it over here with this
group I'll do it in blue so once again
we have eight numbers you're going to
have two middles and so it's going to be
the third and the fourth number which is
11 and 14 and if you if you average 11
and 14
let's see 11 plus 14 is 25 divided by 2
is twelve point five is twelve point
five so this essentially divides the
data into four sections you have
everything up to this first quartile so
you have this first section right over
here or this this first median of the
lower half of the data is 2.5 then you
have everything between two point five
and six then six to twelve point five
and then everything more than twelve
point five and so what a box and whisker
plot is and since that's your graphical
depiction of this right over here so
let's do that I'm going to set up a
number line so let me draw a number line
as straight as possible so let's say
that is my number line and let's say
that this is zero and let's say that
this is I want to make it so let's say
that this is 10 and then this would be
20 and this would be 5 this would be
let me do it a little bit cleaner than
that this would be 1525 would be right
around there so first thing on the
box-and-whisker plot you want to show
the entire range of data so our smallest
data point starts at one so what is
right about here so if I do so this is
two and a half so one is right about
here and then our largest data point is
twenty-two twenty-two would sit right
about there and I'll just see I'll even
label it although you often won't see it
labeled like that that's one and then
that is twenty-two and then the middle
the middle half of the data we do with
the box so the middle half is this
quartile and this quartile right over
there so the second quartile it starts
at two point five so two point five is
right there so this is where we start
our box two point five and then our
third are our third quartile ends at
twelve point five so twelve point five
is right over there
twelve point five is right over there
and then we can draw a box I'll draw the
box in a neutral color I'll do it in
action that yellow color so let me draw
the box here so the box shows where the
middle half of our data is and now I can
draw these two arrows these so that's
the box part and then these two arrows
or what you would call the whisker the
whiskers and that shows where all the
other data is so it's really showing the
spread of the data and then the last
thing we need to show is the actual
median and the median I'll do it in
purple we already figured out is six so
the median sits right about C this is
five this would be seven and a half six
would be right right over there so with
this one diagram you've actually
depicted all of this information in
terms of where is the median the median
is at 6 that is 6 right over there where
is the middle half of the data well it's
between it's between two and a half and
twelve and a half between two and a half
and twelve and a half and all of the
data the entire spread for all the
customers sits between sits between and
this what the whiskers do for us it sits
between 1 and it sits between 22 and if
you wanted a color coded a little bit
let me do that just because it's fun we
could make so this data right over here
this data right over here and really if
you think about its kind of including
this data too that's what this whisker
that's what this whisker is depicting
this data right over here this data
right over let me do that in a different
color this data right over here is kind
of the first half of the box that data
right over here then you have your
median in magenta then this data right
over here is the second part of the box
so it's all of this stuff right over
here and then finally let me pick a new
color that I haven't used yet this data
this data is kind of represented by this
part by this whisker by this whisker
right over here now there's one thing I
want to leave you with is that I use a
method for this box and whisker diagram
I found the median I use a method where
the two halves I got rid of the median
and I found the median of this part and
I found the meeting of that part and
that's the more typical method for box
and whisker plots sometimes when you
find the median of the lower half and
the upper half
some people will include this median in
both sets when they calculate it but I
just want you know that's out there but
the way that I did it is actually the
more mainstream way that's the way most
calculators I believe actually will do a
box and whisker plot